In this part of our optimization tools,
I want to talk about the Merge Actor tool,
as the Merge Actor tool is the basis
for a lot of different optimization workflows inside
of UE5.
Now at its core, what the Merge Actor tool does
is it takes a group of static meshes
and allows you to merge them so
that we get one static mesh.
Now we can take this even further
and merge the materials as well so
that we get one static mesh and one material.
Now in the screen in front of us, we
have an example of an area where merging
would be really beneficial.
This little area here is comprised of 61 static meshes
and 19 materials.
It's also an area that's outside of the interaction
area for this experience.
So this is a lot of static meshes, and more importantly,
a lot of materials that are in an area
that the user isn't going to see up close
or interact with in any way.
So we want to make sure that those areas are
as cheap as possible to render.
We've done this in the image on the right-hand side
by combining all of those meshes into one static mesh
with one material.
Now they both come in at 51k triangles,
but that's not really that big of a concern.
The bigger concern is the amount of meshes
and the amount of materials, because the more that we
can reduce the amount of meshes and materials,
the more we can reduce draw calls
or how many items have to be drawn to the screen per frame,
which is going to increase our performance.
Now to activate the Merge Actor tool,
we're going to go up to our tools
and then select Merge Actors.
And then all of the Merge Actor tool options
will become available.
Let's pop over to the editor now and see how this works.
So again, we're going to come up here to Tools,
and then we're going to go to Merge Actors.
And by default, we have the merge, but if I click on this,
you can see we have Merge, Simplify, Batch,
and Approximate.
So each one of these will merge our actors
in a different way, shape, or form.
Let's take a look at what merge does by selecting
these chairs and this table.
And we're just going to go with the default settings, which
is we're going to disable Merge Materials.
And we're going to go ahead and just select Merge Actors.
We'll come up to our merged assets,
and we will just overwrite this static mesh one.
And that's already done.
Look how quick that was.
Let's just inspect this first and see what we've got.
So 11,908 triangles.
That's not the greatest, but we do
have one mesh with four materials on it.
So if we find this in our Content Browser
here and pull it out, there we go.
So that is one mesh with four materials,
still 11,000 triangles.
We could live with that, but let's see what
else we can do with this tool.
So let's reselect these.
And now what we're going to do
is I'm going to enable our merge materials.
This is going to merge everything down
so that we have one mesh, one material.
Let's go ahead and do that now.
So we're going to say Merge Actors.
We're going to come up here to our merged assets,
and we will just go back over static mesh one
and save that again.
Yes, and that was pretty quick.
So let's just inspect this and see what we have.
So we have one mesh, there we go.
One material, still 11,000 triangles.
But again, that's not too big of an issue.
Let's just pull this out and see what we have.
Now one thing to notice, the statue
itself is actually missing its kind of glass looking texture.
This is one of the things that's kind
of a trade-off between this tool.
You have to make decisions about what
you're going to merge together.
I suggest that you merge things together
that are of similar surface types.
So all three of these would be good.
The reason I would leave this alone
is because of this unique glass material on it.
Remember, merging actors is about optimization
for performance, so we also don't
want to destroy the artwork.
So by merging all this down, we're destroying the artwork.
So again, we're going to have to make
trade-offs for different things.
So let's delete this one out of the scene.
We've still got a few other things in our merge actors
that we can do.
So we have looked at merge.
Let's take a look at simplify.
So let's just go ahead right away,
and we'll leave this with the default settings,
and we'll just merge.
We're going to go up here to merged assets,
and we will take this SMProxy chair and save over the top.
Yes, and we'll give this just a moment to generate,
and we'll be right back.
All right, so that has finished generating.
So let's go ahead and just take
a look at what we got here.
So here's our SMProxy chair.
So let's open this up and see.
We'll check that out.
That's actually kind of cool.
We're at 1,500 triangles, and we've
got one mesh, one material.
So what this has actually done is
it's gone through and recreated this mesh for us.
So let's just pull this out and have a look at it.
So that's actually pretty good.
That looks really, really good considering the fact
that it did for us all automatically.
So that is the simplify.
Simplify is just going to take all that stuff,
simplify it down, and give us a new mesh, new material.
So it's going to reduce our poly and triangle count
as well as reduce our material count.
So that's a big win.
So the next thing that we're going to look at here,
I'm going to select these, and we're going to close this,
and we're going to go to our batch.
So what batch is going to do is it
is going to take our static meshes
and replace them with instanced static mesh versions.
Now, one of the drawbacks to this
is if we have multiple meshes selected
that are all unique meshes, this tool's
not going to work as well.
If we notice right now, it says the current settings
will result in one instanced static mesh component.
Two actors will be replaced.
And what that's telling me is basically
it's only going to be able to replace the chairs because those
are the only things that are identical.
It can't replace the table or the statue
because we don't have any other identical components
for it.
Now, I'm not going to merge the actors on this one,
but I am going to kick it down to approximate.
Now, what approximate does is it generates new mesh,
new material, but this is more
geared towards when you're trying to merge Nanite meshes.
Now, it will work on regular static meshes,
but it is geared towards Nanite meshes.
Let's go ahead and see how this works by just
clicking the Merge Actors button now.
We're going to come up here to our merged assets,
and we will do this approximate SM chair.
Click Save, Override, and we'll be back in just a moment
once this finishes.
All right, now that that has finished,
let's go ahead and see what the results are
by hitting Control-Space.
And I believe it was the right here.
No, it was the approximate chair, so there we go.
There's the approximate chair.
So that has done quite a number on this.
Let's go ahead and take a look at what its stats are.
So 1998, that's pretty good.
One mesh, one material, but we do have some issues there.
We're getting some kind of crazy looking geometry.
But again, remember, this is trying
to work for Nanite meshes or meshes that have
tons of detail inside of them.
So when you are going through using Merge Actors,
there are also a number of settings inside of this tool
that will help adjust how everything is corrected.
I highly suggest that everybody take a look
at these settings and adjust, build,
so you can more familiarize yourselves
with how each mode in the Merge Actor tool
works and how it can help benefit your project's meshes.